taking a look at walker bueller who is
third in the league and wins he's second
in the league behind just freddie
peralta in era
it's a race for the dodgers against the
san francisco giants and of course
pushing them a little bit as a san diego
padres but for walker bueller it could
also start the beginning of a cy young
race
he always loves pitching in the big
games and
boy if it didn't feel like a big game in
the build-up it certainly has since the
gates opened up and a packed house has
filed in
working from the first space side of the
rubber bueller's 1-1
and altuve lines this one into center
field that'll get down for a base hit
played on a hop by taylor and jose
altuve is aboard to lead off the ball
game always been a good high fast ball
hitter and he did a nice job in the
first pitch of the game and he does an
even better job on this one it's a
little lower and michael brandley just
having a very michael brantley like here
one of the most underrated consistent
hitters in baseball leading the majors
at 3 31 coming in here
off the hands to second that's the
second one
it is the first double play
in the first inning that i've ever seen
a standing ovation for this is unlike
anything i've ever seen in the regular
season
a really nice turn by mookie betts to
start that
and miss break three correa down on
strikes
no runs one hit nobody left after the
first half of the first astros nothing
and the dodgers are coming up lance
mccullers jr is gonna be that
right-handed arm on the mound for the
astros to start this quick two-game
series
doing a very good job this season 8-2
records six of those wins coming on the
road doing a great job in that gray
uniform this year 3-2-3 era and still
holding hitters under a 200 average
bets digs it out serves it into left
center for a lead off baseball
how about 96 with that fastball lance
picks up and out with a strikeout it's a
good arm side movement again that
two-seamer lance has talked about it he
creates movement because of that grip
and the way his arm releases that
baseball
turner hits one to right michael
brantley doesn't have to move very far
and puts it away for out number two one
two
and that is strike three call a slider
over the inner third froze smith and the
inning is over
the dodgers strand a couple after a hit
and a walk and after one astros nothing
dodgers nothing
on the ground against the ship that's a
fair ball down the left field line it'll
bounce off the stands and tuck her into
second base sliding with a double kyle
tucker with a two out double for the
astros in the second not a bad job by
kyle right there keeping that ball fair
the 3-1
swinging a pop-up
and a short left center field sprinting
in chris taylor calling off aj pollock
in short left center the catch is made
and the inning is over 1-1 ground ball
left side into the ship backhanded by
altuve jump throw to first on a hop and
diaz able to scoop it for the out
excellent play on both ends altuve to
the left of second in the shift and
still able to nab pollock
for the second out of the inning as
bellinger goes to second he knew he was
only going to have one play he was not
going to have a chance to get the force
at second based on where the baseball
was hit and he knows that bellinger runs
well so he erased that the 2-2 from
bueller maldonado swings and he lines it
to right center field that's in the gap
it'll split the outfielders and go to
the wall chris taylor the center fielder
peels it off the warning track and sends
it back in and it's a leadoff double for
maldonado his eighth two base hit of the
season fueler right now with 50 pitches
thrown in the game more than he would
like at this point the astros trying to
get on the board first with the major
league leader in batting average hitting
here with a 3-2 count brantley lines one
to right field that ball will be down
into the wall astros take the lead
michael brantley an rbi double it's one
nothing houston on the 27th double of
the year for brantley they've been
testing man walker bueller was trying to
get inside there both with the fastball
and the cut fastball bradley at second a
2-2 pitch
punches one to first for max muncie
that'll do it for the third the astros
get the game's first run on a michael
brantley double fourth game for bueller
one going in the fifth brings up michael
brantley
pulls it sharply monkey
makes the play
right field second base it doesn't
matter
gold glove caliber
it's a bird it's a plane it's mookie
outstanding
so much fun to watch mookie betts had a
line drive of his own to get to the
baseball
the 2-2
swing and a miss
fastball by turner upstairs and the
inning is over seventh strikeout for
mccullers he works around bueller's lead
off hit
and we're through five in la astros one
dodgers number so this is empty two gone
and bueller to face tucker trying to
again get through six
three two
and it's inside ball four and that may
be the end of the line for bueller mark
prior and dave roberts chatting as the
left-handed bedding and light-hitting
robel garcia comes up on the hands corey
seeger walker beauty through six again
holding the astros to just one
dodgers have only three hits against
mccullers and only one over the last
four innings
got him that's eight for lance mccullers
he has had at least eight strikeouts now
in six consecutive starts
riveting stuff tonight in l.a cutter
starts the bottom of the seventh he's
allowed just three hits pitch on the way
and he swings and he hits the ground
ball off of mccullers it bounces to
third throw over gets away from diaz
taking a left turn as pollock and he'll
be in at second base and the cullers
will be checked out as he is down into a
squat behind third base plants is going
to stay in there here's the 1-2 and
baity waves and misses and strikes out
again with the curve ball he kept going
back to the curve and beatty could not
catch up though a strikeout the ninth or
mccullers and now back to the top of the
order mookie bets
he takes the left
passes the baton to max muncie that'll
do it for that's mccarth
got him what a spot for blake taylor
lance mccullers jr fired up blake
strikes out max muncie to get through
seven innings one on and one out for
jordan alvarez who's over three lined
out to center his last time
you're not drives one deep to right
field that ball is gone
you're not alvarez in dodger stadium
with his first career hit against his
former organization puts the astros in
front three to nothing that's one for
three with a walk
2-2 up the middle altuve is there
the astros win three to nothing stannic
ends the game on a 100 mile an hour
fastball to induce a groundout for his
third career save